this video was made possible by
curiosity stream subscribe to their
nebula bundle deal at
curiositystream.comwendover to watch an
exclusive companion video to this
it's really just four lanes a median and
some on and off ramps the interstate
highway system is no engineering marvel
no unprecedented undertaking no
massively innovative concepts it's a
simple idea one that arose since the
earliest days of the automobile it's not
exciting which is why it often goes so
underappreciated take the interstates
away though and you have a weaker nation
you have one with dramatically starker
regional divides one with increased
decentralization more specifically you
have a nation absent of a noticeable
portion of the late 1900s economic
development and transformation
these words like the system itself still
aren't exciting but put more simply if
you are an american regardless of
whether you use the interstate system
your life would be noticeably different
in a reality without the interstates
it's a single collection of roadways
with an influence so great that it
permeates into every american's life
it all started here 102 years ago
79 vehicles departed from the white
house's ellipse at 11 15 am on july 7th
1919. they snaked through the district
streets before crossing into maryland
and stopping for lunch in rockville at
12 30 p.m
the coupling on one of their kitchen
trailers broke and a car's fan bells too
but all in all it was an uneventful
seven hour 46 mile 74 kilometer journey
to the frederick fairgrounds
twelve and a half hours later they woke
up left drove arrived and slept again
this cycle repeated itself day after day
they cut 40 or 50 or 60 miles deeper
into their westward journey the convoy
climbed through the heights of the
appalachian mountains trek through the
mud of ohio before crossing the
mississippi river at 4 10 p.m on july
22nd
from there they entered an area defined
by desolation
few dared venture west in a motor
vehicle in 1919 always opting for the
relative comfort and speed of passenger
trains
this convoy though was making the
journey specifically to determine just
how difficult this feat was to what
extent such a journey was feasible for
military logistics purposes
the answer came quickly
despite routing themselves on the most
developed transcontinental road of the
time the lincoln highway they constantly
had to divert around disrepair
physically disassemble covered bridges
to get their trucks through and fight
physics on roads too narrow for an
oncoming car to pass
gas stations were few and far between so
such travel required truly expedition
level planning
each time they entered a city though
they were greeted by hordes of intrigued
locals and dignitaries but those crowds
thinned as the convoy crawled further
into the desolate west
most but certainly not all of their
vehicles successfully traversed the
rockies and the same can be said for
their trip across some of the lincoln
highway's roughest roads in utah with
time though the trend reversed roads
improved and they finally saw pavement
again as the convoy entered california
its final state
after a final evening in oakland
california the vehicles loaded onto a
ferry crossed the bay and made a
ceremonious arrival in san francisco
accompanied by a massive parade and a
formal dinner
that was september 6 1919
62 days after their departure from the
white house ellipse having concentrated
nearly all their waking hours on driving
the math works out to an average travel
speed of just 5.65 miles or 9 kilometers
per hour a staggeringly slow pace on a
road branded as a highway in a year
featuring technologies such as electric
refrigerators airplanes and long
distance phone service the convoy
accomplished its mission of appraising
the feasibility of this route for more
practical military purposes but the
report back to washington was not
positive one lieutenant colonel tasked
with observing the journey wrote quote
extended trips by trucks through the
middle western part of the united states
are impractical until the roads are
improved and then only a light truck
should be used on long halls it was
clear that for now until roads were
improved transcontinental motor trips
would remain the domain of publicity
stunts and enthusiasts
but then the years started passing
administration after administration
observing the growing presence of motor
vehicles in the lives of increasingly
everyday americans recognized that road
construction was not something that
could be left the responsibility of
states while individual states did make
plenty of progress building high quality
urban and rural roads their interests
were insular
iowa for example would have no interest
building a highway with the primary
purpose of connecting illinois to
nebraska as americans went off to fight
in europe during world war ii they
observed the efficiency of germany's
national reichs autobahn highway system
but when they returned home they were
forced to navigate a patchwork of state
systems of varying quality to get
anywhere beyond their local areas
in the 1950s when america was a mere
decade out from landing men on the moon
it still took significant planning in
the better part of 10 days to reasonably
traverse from one coast to the other
while this might have been inconvenient
for road tripping americans it mostly
meant that there were regions that
simply could not compete with coastal
areas in the industrial sector due to
high transport costs and times it was
clear something had to change but
efforts to increase highway construction
at the federal level were constantly
stalled by funding issues and a general
lack of volition
but then came someone new
one of the members of the 1919
transcontinental convoy in fact the very
lieutenant colonel who provided the
earlier report on the journey to
washington continued on in his military
career and rose to the ranks until he
became supreme allied commander of the
european theater in world war ii
then upon return to the u.s he entered a
political career culminating with his
inauguration as president on january
20th 1953
this was of course dwight d
eisenhower
with the groundwork laid by decades of
planning and false starts eisenhower's
task was centered on finally finding the
political will and funding to turn this
concept map a 1955 publication by the
bureau of public roads into reality
after nearly three years of political
maneuvering he succeeded on june 29th
the federal-aid highway act of 1956 was
signed dedicating some 25 billion
dollars to constructing 41 000 miles or
66 000 kilometers of highway unlike
previous attempts at similar programs
the federal government would now pay 90
of the costs of these interstate
highways with individual states
responsible for the rest largely funded
by a hike in the federal gas tax
just three months after the bill's
signing paving work began on a section
of interstate 70 in kansas and two
months after that the same section
opened to the public representing the
first miles of a system that would
engulf the country over the coming
decades
now whether it's i-40 in tennessee or
i-90 through idaho the way these roads
were built was highly highly
standardized
that was after all the points these
standards are codified in a simple
eight-page document entitled a policy on
design standards interstate system
to start with fundamentally interstates
must have controlled access meaning the
manner in which vehicles enter or exit
the roadway must be controlled through
on and off ramps that's why unlike with
many state highways you never see
intersections with stop lights on
interstates except when rules are
violated
the standards also set out a minimum
speed 50 miles or 80 kilometers per hour
in urban and mountainous areas 70 miles
or 110 kilometers per hour in rural
areas and maximum grade up to seven
percent corresponding to 370 feet of
elevation gain per mile of road or 70
meters per kilometer depending on speed
and topography there must be at least
two lanes in each direction of travel 12
feet or 3.5 meters in width with a cross
slope essentially an angle to allow for
rain runoff of at least 1.5 and ideally
2 percent grade tunnels and bridges must
have at least 16 feet or 5 meters of
vertical clearance although less is
allowed through urban areas as long as
an alternate route with 16-foot
clearance is available aside from a few
smaller details that's the entirety of
the interstate highway design standards
it's incredibly simple
implementing this nationwide however
was no simple endeavor
when the project started in the 50s one
mile of interstate cost some 8.5 million
dollars to construct or 5.3 million
dollars per kilometer however through
the decades as labor costs rose and the
simplest sections stood completed this
ramped up to over 34 million dollars per
mile or 21 million dollars per kilometer
unsurprisingly the interstate system
quickly blew past its original 25
billion budget allocation but people and
governments were convinced the project
gained more and more funding and was
reaching completion by the time the 80s
turned into the 90s
to complete the original vision just one
last section remains
a 12 and a half mile 20 kilometer
stretch through glenwood canyon colorado
with thousand foot walls flanking on
each side little room exists aside the
colorado river for a roadway but a
complex collection of bridges and
tunnels were constructed at a cost of
960 million dollars inflation adjusted
corresponding to 75 million per mile or
47 million dollars per kilometer of
roadway
once this engineering marvel was
completed in 1992 however the nation was
connected and more than two decades
after his death eisenhower's vision
was realized
his 62-day transcontinental expedition
from 1919 now takes a mere 42 hours
in such a decentralized country
consisting of a patchwork of states each
with unique governments laws cultures
and more the consistency of a nationwide
federal transportation system is in and
of itself unique it is one of the most
regular interactions americans
especially in far-flung western and
southern regions might have with a
federal program today the largest urban
center located further than 25 miles or
40 kilometers from an interstate highway
is fresno california with a population
of about half a million in fact only 14
cities with over 100 000 people are
located further than this distance
even alaska hawaii and puerto rico are
now included in this program despite the
fact that their interstates don't
actually extend interstate with wide
lanes smooth turns consistent grades and
more these highways are remarkably safe
while nationwide the us averages 1.3
deaths per 100 million vehicle miles
traveled interstates for the same 100
million vehicle miles observe just 0.55
deaths each year
incredibly that means that assuming the
alternative is equivalent to travel on
non-interstate roads this system is
responsible for saving about 6 500 lives
per year
beyond the moral component the innate
human desire to preserve life the u.s
department of transportation on a
statistical basis values a human life at
11.7 million dollars when evaluating
potential safety standards
so the safety profile of the interstate
highway system by itself has a
theoretical economic impact of about 75
billion dollars per year therefore
easily justifying its cost alone
but then there's the more direct impacts
among the more populated states
construction disproportionately took
place in southern states such as georgia
south carolina or arkansas on a basis of
miles constructed per capita then in
less populous states the interstate
disproportionately penetrated the
american west with states such as utah
montana nevada and wyoming receiving the
most miles per capita therefore it was
the south and west that received the
greatest impact in essence what these
roadways did was connect the us's
economic centers to the periphery so the
periphery had the most to gain by
effectively reducing the relative
distance to centers by a factor of 30
percent on average in the case of
interstate 5 for example which runs
along the entire west coast from the
border to mexico to that with canada
california the state that encompasses
the majority of its distance actually
sees the smallest benefit that's not to
say the benefit is small the removal of
the interstate would correspond to a six
percent loss in overall income in the
state but oregon the 12th most sparsely
populated state in the nation would lose
15 percent of its income if i-5 simply
disappeared
it's worth fully considering just how
staggering that statistic is
a single simple four-lane roadway
stretching some 300 miles or 500
kilometers through oregon attributable
for 15
of its income
this does however make sense
oregon's economy significantly
undergirded by the natural resources
manufacturing and agricultural sectors
is highly trade dependent the state does
not however have any major export ports
so when a manufacturer in salem oregon
for example needs to transport the
finished products to the port of oakland
it would likely hire a truck to take the
9 hour journey south on i-5 the shortest
non-interstate route however would take
13 and a half hours on roads with
potentially burdensome weight
restrictions inadequate facilities low
bridges and other constraints it just
makes getting product out harder now
ultimately transport cost is rarely an
enormous portion of a given product's
cost a five cent increase on a 10
product produced further from oakland
isn't massive but that's not the context
that matters in the competition between
places for industry if the options are
between a state that has a conduit
enabling lower cost reliable fast
transportation in and out and all other
factors are the same why would a
manufacturer decide to locate in the
more poorly connected place
the economy is a competition and in
competition the smallest margins matter
even when they don't in a
non-competitive context considering the
alternative was the status quo
individual states building their own
highways disconnected from any national
program
this program caught the states that
couldn't afford massive infrastructure
projects many of which were in the south
and west up to the rest
therefore interstates made these states
more competitive but reducing their
relative distance to the rest of the
world
that's not to say the program was
perfect though just as much as it proved
revolutionary to more rural areas
it gutted cities
neighborhoods predominantly poorer ones
were leveled to the ground to make space
for interstates and their associated
infrastructure this often created clear
physical barriers between certain
neighborhoods and urban centers which
reduced opportunity in these excluded
neighborhoods they also had the effect
of encouraging reduced density which
increases the environmental impact of
cities create scenarios where job
opportunity is linked to car ownership
and additional potential negative
impacts
altogether the way in which interstates
interact with cities was often poorly
planned and executed but when examined
in aggregate
the interstate highway system is one of
the best investments the united states
ever made
while by no means unique to the united
states in concept the vastness and
regional disparities in the country
meant such a system had a uniquely
powerful impact
for every dollar spent on the program it
has returned at least six in economic
benefits in the context of nations
connectivity is power therefore the
reason why the interstate highway system
is the most impactful infrastructure
program in american history is simply
because
as of now
it's the largest
i definitely enjoy nerding out about the
interstates and hopefully you now do too
so i made a whole other video about the
strangest quirkiest sections of the
system like why interstate 180 exists
just connecting to a town of 700 and
traveled on by only about 100 vehicles
per hour or the town that essentially
exists because one of the only stop
lights on an interstate you can watch
that video on nebula the streaming site
founded by myself and loads of your
favorite educational creators there's no
algorithm meaning we can upload without
worrying about how clickbaity a video is
and no ads or sponsorships meaning you
can just enjoy the videos themselves
plus we regularly release exclusive
companion videos extended cuts big
budget originals and more what makes
nebula even better is the best way to
get access to it the curiosity stream
bundle deal you sign it through them and
then you also get access to curiosity
stream home to an enormous catalog of
top-quality non-fiction shows and
documentaries like highway to the arctic
about canada's annual endeavor to build
ice roads through its frozen north to
provide a seasonal road connection for
many of its most isolated villages
nebula and curiosity stream are both
fantastic streaming sites that i find
myself regularly using and they come at
an incredible price just 14.79 a year
with the current sale at
curiositystream.comwendover
or by clicking this button that's all
our regular videos early and ad free
exclusive companion videos big budget
nebula originals and an enormous number
of non-fiction shows and documentaries
for an annual price similar to what you
probably pay monthly for other streaming
sites and signing up help support this
channel so go sign up at
curiositystream.com
wendover